Раніше на цьому ринку в центрі Єревана було дуже людно.
Речовий ринок ФірдусІ заманював покупцІв доступними цінами.
Приблизно рік тому влада вирішила закрити ринок,
сьогодні тут залишилося лише кілька торгових точок.
Влада хоче знести весь квартал і використати землю для своїх потреб:
на місці старих будинків побудувати сучасний комплекс -
квартири, офіси, підземну парковку.
Протягом двадцяти п'яти років у Анаіт була своя торгова точка на ринку Фірдусі.
Відколи ринок закрили, її сім'я отримує лише 75 євро на місяць:
на мізерну субсидію мають прожити вона сама, її донька і хвора мати.
Держава хоче викупити також ділянку, на якій стоїть їхній будинок.
Але компенсація, яку пропонує влада, - занадто маленька,
з огляду на центральне розташування, вважає Анаіт.
Вже сто років моєму будинку. Мій дім ніби антикваріат.
Я яку ціну хочу - ту і можу назвати.
Це моя власність, моя особиста власність.
Яке вони мають право мою власність забирати?
Моя дитина, моя мати тут.
Я не уявляю, як можна власність красти. А вони крадуть.
Анаіт, як і багато інших мешканців кварталу, звинувачує уряд країни в корупції.
Вони теж брали активну участь у нещодавніх протестах.
У Вірменії 30% населення живуть за межею бідності,
і кожен п'ятий не має роботи.
Масові протести в столиці Вірменії були викликані рішенням екс-президента країни
Сержа Саргсяна обійняти пост прем'єра і залишитися при владі,
по суті, на третій термін.
Протестувальники відчувають себе обдуреними.
Вони хочуть оновлення влади, яку вважають корумпованою.
Існує попит на зміни, і це йде не від невеликої кількості людей
з еліти, уряду або опозиції,
це потреба суспільства, і очікування у людей дуже високі.
Повернімося до ринку Фірдусі.
Анаіт показує нам свою ділянку, яку хоче викупити влада.
Я взагалі навіть за мільйон не віддам. Це моя земля!
Зелена оаза прямо в центрі міста має для родини Анаіт
не лише матеріальну цінність.
Ось уже сто років ця ділянка належить сім'ї Пхрікян.
Моя донька каже, ми маємо залишити це і поїхати звідси.
А куди це залишати? Наші землі, наші кладовища.
Мій батько тут похований. У мене бабуся, дідусь тут поховані.
Чому я маю йти? Чому? Хай вони залишають. Вони мають мільярди!
Реконструкція кварталу ще не почалася,
але його мешканцям  набридло терпіти корупцію у владі.
Тепер вони самі хочуть вирішувати, яким буде їхнє майбутнє.